you have fantastic hair all right oh my
god thank you everybody looks so great
right now
this we just threw it on
canada's got talent i think you are the
future one of the best parts of these
shows is you get blown away by people's
talents doing things that you didn't
even know somebody could be that talent
at doing some people came out on that
stage and my response i think i might
have just said this right to them too
i'm like you
are weird this is the weirdest thing
i've ever seen i didn't even know this
was a thing
i freaking love it you see these things
that come on stage and and
there's some of them where i'm just
looking around i'm like is anybody else
seeing this like
like you like you just see some of the
some of the some of the wildest things
how do you wind up as host of canada's
got talent
i remember my
my interview for the host position and i
was so nervous and i
nervous anymore i know what that feels
like i know what it feels like to be in
that spotlight standing in that star in
the middle of the stage having a
performance go incredibly well and then
having a performance go incredibly not
well how you are the longest serving
judge on got talent and what made you
the most proud about coming back up here
and doing this with with uh with all
canadians i am so proud of just my
heritage my culture and the fact that i
am from canada and how much talent
really comes out of canada that people
don't know what's that thing that you
have that maybe we don't know that
you're really damn good at it is to
throw candy in the air and catch it
should i be on stage because i feel like
this is championship level
talent if i was judging you girl that's
a golden buzzer
like boom that's it
how are we in your head right now do you
already have a front runner you are
amazing you are a star person i think of
that will probably win and not only win
but will become an international
household name superstar
[Music]